ils ont résisté jusqu'à la 30e minute
ouvrant même le score sur une pénalité
mais avec un essai en contre de bagneux
à la fin de la première mi temps les
versets les cracks énormément de
frustration
on est très très bien sur la première mi
temps et sur la deuxième on perds un peu
les pédales on perd un peu les pieds on
passe conférence mais plus à la faute
il ya plus beaucoup plus d'erreurs et du
cou
déroutant peu de nombreuses fautes de
main la défaillance du buteur et un
deuxième essai marqué là aussi en contre
par l'adversaire la descente en division
d'honneur est difficile pour les
versaillais n'est pas en confiance la
descente dans l'année dernière date
fédérale 3 en honneur fait que les
joueurs n'ont pas trop confiance en eux
et doute aussi et encore une fois ce qui
fait que l'on marque pas les points
qu'on doit marquer et derrière on se met
à douter et deux trois petites fautes de
notre part et c'est l'adversaire qui
score alors que c'est nous qui
produisons tous je crois score final 3 à
17 2 échecs en deux matchs pour les
hommes d'alain jamin mais l'équipe ne
baisse pas les bras
pour les joueurs ce sera la dernière
défaite à domicile